امين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسي
ناتو يانس طوطن بارك قال في مؤتمر صحفي
انه لا يمكن السماح لروسيا بالانتصار في
حربها على اوكرانيا
بوت خطاين استراتيجيين كبيرين اولهما
عندما قرر اجتياح اوكرانيا في فبراير من
العام الجاري سابوت تقدير شجاعه
الاوكرانيين وقدرتهم على القتال كما اساء
تقدير دعم حلف الناتو لاوكرانيا اعتقد
الرئيس الروسي انه يستطيع اجتياح اوكرانيا
في بضعه ايام واليوم بعد تسعه اشهر ما
زالت روسيا تشهد خساره سلوى الاخرى حراره
اوكرانيا بعد اراضيها واحداثها كان منطقه
خيرسون وهي تواصل ذلك
جمعيه البرلمانيه في مدريد مراسل الجزيره
عبد الله الشعب البدايه اهميه هذا
الاجتماع لجمعيه البرلمانيه القضاء في
نيته وابرز ما قاله يا استاذ طارق في
كلمته امام الجنيه
نعم عبد الصمد اهميه الاجتماع بالدرجه
الاولى هو كونه يضم البرلمانات الدول
الاعضاء في الحلف وهو يناقش في الملف
الاول ملف عضويه كل من فنلندا والسويد
الذين قال عنهم الامين العام انهم الان
اصبحوا جاهزين للانضمام بالطبع عمليه
الانضمام تستلزم موافقه وتصديق برلمانات
هذه الدول بقيه فقط كل من تركيا والمجر
لكي تتم عمليه الانضمام قائلا انها ان ان
البلدين ما بما يلزم خصوصا الاشتراطات
التركيه في ما يخص ملف مكافحه الارهاب
وغيرها من الشروط التي وضعتها انقره على
كل من ستوكهولم واهل سينكي للتصديق همم
بالنسبه للمتجر المتجر همم يعني خلال ايام
مقبله قبل نهايه العام ستقوم بالتصديق
وتبقى تركيا وسط مبارح في كلامه اليوم قال
ان البلدان همم اصبح جاهزين لكي يصبح همم
كلا منهما همم يعني همم يجعلها عدد الدول
في 32 بدلا من 30 حاليا اهميه الاجتماع
ايضا تاتي بعد القمه التي عقدت فيها هذا
الصيف في شهر يونيو هنا في مدريد قمه
الناتو لمناقشه ما تم الاتفاق عليه من
قرارات خصوصا في ملف الدعم اوكرانيا
عسكريا وكذلك ملف تقويه الجبهه الشرقيه
الدول التي تقع في شرق اوروبا التي لديها
حدود مع روسيا سولتنبر قال انه تمت مضاعفه
عدد القوات هناك وكذلك التواجد البري
والبحر والجوي وكذلك ايضا قال ان هناك
تدرج في استغناء دول الحلف عن مصادر
الطاقه مما اسمها الدول السلطويه في اشاره
الى روسيا والصين قائله من الاتحاد
يتم ابتزازه من قبل روسيا في هذا الملف
وبالتالي همم سار ضروريه لاستغرارا عن هذا
الامر وطبيعه الحال هذا الاجتماع استمر
على مدار اربعه ايام وسينتهي بيان يصدر
يحدد الخ- الخطوات المقبله في ما يخص
تحركات النيته قبل القمه المقبله في يوليو
في ليتوانيا في مدينه فيلناس
بنات الدول الاعضاء همم يعني همم هل هناك
اي خطوات اوروبيه ما زالت همم
اوراق بياده الاتحاد الاوروبي او
الاوروبيين وعموما والدول اضافه نيته همم
لاستخدامها ضد همم روسيا خاصه سلاح
العقوبات الذي فعلته بشكل كبير في بدايه
الازمه
في هذا الملف يعني الاوروبيون الذين
يشكرون اكثر من 80% من دول الحلف يرون ان
هناك همم يعني همم حاجه الى التدرج في
ربما اقرار الحزمه التاسعه التي كانت
اقتراحتها دول البلطيقه في ما يخص
العقوبات على روسيا بالنظر الى ان كثيرا
من العقوبات لم يتم تفعيلها بشكل رسمي حتى
الان البعض منها لا زال خصوصا الحزمه
السادسه والسابعه التي تختصان بمنع ايقاف
منع استيرا الغاز من روسيا وكذلك ان نفطر
فلان حيز التنفيذ فقط بعد ايام في بدايه
ديسمبر لكن هل في النيته من ناحيته يقول
انه في المقام الاول يعني من خلال شركاه
سواء في الاتحاد الاوروبيه او غيرها من
الدول
يحكم الحصار او يضيق الخناقه على موسكو
فيما يخص تمويلها لهذه الحرب هو يقول ايضا
ان ملف العقوبات وبالدرجه الاولى في يدها
هؤلاء الحلفاء خصوصا الاتحاد الاوروبي
وانه من ناحيته عسكريا يمنع او يسعى لم
خروج هذه الحرب عن نطاق اوكرانيا لكي
يستطيع ربما عدم ااا يعني لك لا تدخل شكرا
ولا الحلف في حرب مع روسيا خصوصا في
الفتره الاخيره بعد سقوط صاروخين في
بولندا ومنع يعني ما قيل في وقتها السابق
نشوف حرب جديده بين الطرفين شكرا جزيلا
عبد الله الشامي مراسل الجزيره من مقر
اجتماعيه البرلمانيه
شكرا لك